washington had a great effort and there
was a graphic yesterday
that blew me away you know we're
watching all the games at once and
yesterday there were eight games at once
so you see flashes and you see bits and
you hear audio of only one game at a
time
and i'm not the one who controls it and
there's times matt casey where it drives
me crazy but that's a different story
altogether
i looked up to the upper left corner of
the screen
and i saw a graphic that the washington
football team which has been around
forever has only ever erased
a 17 point fourth quarter deficit
once in the existence of the franchise
and yesterday was almost number two down
20 to three entering the fourth quarter
they pulled it close 20 to 15 they had a
chance
and look credit to them for even getting
themselves in position to do something
that only been done once before in
franchise history
but it ultimately didn't work out the
seahawks hold on and washington proving
to everyone that they can play with
anyone
no doubt you're exactly right you know
the game
you know when it got to 23 is a little
misleading anyways it really is
you know dwayne haskins early on hey
he's young and he hasn't played a lot so
he wasn't perfect early but as the game
went on and he settled in he did some
good things he really did
i mean it made me feel good for him
certainly but
one of the crucial mistakes of the
football game and again
when you haven't played a lot and you're
a young quarterback you're going to do
stuff like this every now and then
but it's six to nothing it's the second
quarter it's late in the second quarter
it's a defensive struggle you could tell
that it looks like every washington game
we watch every week
their defense is going to keep them in
it can their offense make a drive or two
to get them within the score
and then can their defense make a play
and maybe score
or or can their offense come through in
the clutch late in the game with some
ugly drive to win the football game
that's what they do
it was kind of setting up that way it's
six to nothing and dwayne haskins gets a
little pressure he runs to his right
throws that interception right mike as
he's running there down in the goal line
wasn't a great decision to throw that
ball
but the seahawks intercept it and that
leads to a long drive russell wilson
broke a long run a few passes all of a
sudden they score a touchdown
and it was 13 nothing and that's really
the spot that hurt washington yeah they
battled back
but that game was looking like it was
going to shape into some
16 10 16 9 16 13 type game
and it just got a little away from
washington there in that moment and made
them play a game they didn't necessarily
want to play
still in first place with two games left
in the nfc they're amazing they win that
division that will be an incredible
accomplishment for a team that is rife
or at least had been rife
with dysfunction hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports